we all expected him to win I think that
it brings Ali got into a second ballot I
think wouldn't have happened if you had
this vote a week ago and I think that's
the impact of the events of this week
but I think this isn't over by any means
the events of this week is so traumatic
for FIFA that I cannot see FIFA
reforming itself and the blatta it's at
16 years to reform it he hasn't done it
he disappointed that alley pull down no
I expected him I think if you're that
close I think he would have got it he
could have got to set a lower vote the
second time because I think a lot of
people are going to get planes and they
would have said hang on he's quite
clearly not going to got not going to
win but it was a good vote does this
decision Greg mean that's England's may
be more likely to withdraw from future
World Cups England won't withdraw from
anything on its own let me be absolutely
certain about that that would be
ridiculous there will be discussions i
think in fifa about this result and what
things should do next but that won't be
England alone but you would welcome
dialogue now with UEFA it's a
possibility now I wouldn't even say it's
a possible i think they were there are
other decisions but i honestly I think
the events of this week is so profound
and if you listen to what the attorneys
in the match and in general and America
said this is the beginning and not the
end I think there's an awful lot more to
for this to play out